[Music]
hello everyone
[Music]
my name is bradley and today i'm going
to talk about the technology
which in just a couple of years
has turned from
somewhat of a gimmick
into well the everyday
normality
so i'm going to ask you a question
what could be easier than paying for
coffee or lunch with paypass
well only probably losing your money
today we're going to be looking at the
overall safety of contactless payment
methods
[Music]
the coronavirus pandemic has changed our
habits entirely we learned how to wear
masks on a daily basis work remotely and
we're also getting used to using
contactless payment a lot more back in
early 2020 only 26 of britain's used
such systems and just six months later
the number grew to 40 percent
and i remember you know very vaguely
when this technology first appeared in
the uk in 2007. now the law allowed only
small purchases to be paid for in this
way with a maximum of 10 pounds
in 2012 the limit was doubled and in
october last year it was increased by
another factor up to 100 pounds can be
spent in just one contactless
transaction now today three quarters of
all mastercard transactions in europe
take place through contactless means and
by 2026 this market is planned to grow
threefold every year up to six trillion
dollars will be transferred from account
to account without the entering of pin
codes sms confirmation or even check
signing now banks benefit from this what
we used to pay for with small bank notes
and coins well this now gets put through
the banks with each payment the bank
receives small percentage for the
overseeing of the transaction for me
paying for everyday expenses with a
watch or a phone is much more convenient
than fiddling around with notes in my
pocket and looking for change in my bag
more and more often i find myself
leaving the house without my wallets at
all i can just use apple pay
okay could cyber criminals really leave
such a fat piece of the market untouched
of course not like the planet
i don't wanna shut up
now
what's this
a wireless banking terminal i got my
hands on one of these now these are
often used in cafes small shops fairs
and similar places i'm sure you've seen
one of these before now it's got a
powerful battery communicates with the
bank fire wi-fi or even cellular network
now i bought this on ebay and it cost me
well i think around 30 pounds
so now i can arrange a hunt for the
owners of bank cards right all you need
to do is stealthily approach a person in
the ground
snuggle up to them on the bus maybe and
simply just
press the card reader against
their wallet maybe in their pocket
well would that work i don't know the
main thing is to set an amount in
advance no more than 99 pounds so the
terminal doesn't ask you to enter the
pin the first victim should pay off the
venture three times over and then well a
solid profit's been made as if come on i
mean nothing will come out of this
venture now what i was thinking of my
brilliant plan right
well i was thinking as a buyer not as a
seller and i completely forgot about the
role of the bank in all of this when you
pay with a contactless card the money is
actually withdrawn from you immediately
but this doesn't mean that they
immediately end up in the seller's
pocket
in fact they hang around for at least
two or three days in a special bank
account and this is done to avoid
conflict situations in case of
in case of say technical failures
and also to combat fraud and money
laundering now imagine if i start
walking down oxford street and debiting
money from other people's cards the bank
will immediately notice suspicious
activity just one complaint about a
suspicious debit and my account will be
blocked so long read a technique
theoretically i could make payments
through foreign banks for example i
could do it through a vpn channel and
drive operations through some i don't
know unscrupulous bank in tanzania but
it's all too complicated and well
corrupt for knocking off simple pocket
money i would have spent so much on its
organization that well it would cancel
out any earnings i would have got what
does that mean anyway i want you to
imagine a picture let's say we're on the
london underground and at first i have
to push through you with this strange
cumbersome looking reader i might stand
next to you strangely for a few seconds
pressing close but then i've also got to
try to leave right
besides with such a unit in your hands
anyone standing there is going to see
the situation and call the police in a
minute stop right there criminal scum
and it won't be possible to read the
information from a greater distance with
a standard terminal either the antenna
parameters and power are selected so as
to work confidently only at the closest
of distances a much more elegant fraud
scheme is associated with such terminals
imagine that you went over to have a
beer in a small bar somewhere in isn't
it riga latvia just beer nothing more
you pay you see the amount of five euros
on the terminal screen you decide to add
it up by leaving a tip right
you don't even pay attention to the fact
that the terminal routes have paper and
you weren't given a receipt
what happens right it's only later that
you found out that 50 euros have been
debited from your account the scammers
used a terminal with a fake display or a
modified program on the screen you see
five euros but a completely different
payment goes to the bank indeed you
won't be able to prove anything you were
in this fine establishment and you paid
for the beer yourself and you don't have
a receipt for five euros either now to
protect yourself from such a situation
enable payment notifications it'll be
much easier to deal with scammers on the
spot then
usually they will agree that a mistake
has been made and will quietly return
the money to you you never go to the bar
again and all as well to understand both
the real and imaginary dangers of
contactless payment systems i'll have to
go all the way back to the prototype of
modern cards
charga plate steel tokens
so look this is what a credit card
looked like a hundred years ago before
its appearance credit cards were simply
printed on paper
they were issued by organizations that
were ready to sell you goods on credit
your name was entered on the card with
sometimes the maximum purchase amount
and also the validity period of the
offer
in store or at a gas station the cash
has simply copied this data into the
transaction log now of course it took a
lot of time and paper cards quickly got
dirty and torn
therefore the guys from boston
barrington manufacturing went the other
way they took the army's dog tags as
inspiration they created small steel
plates on which letters were pressed out
with a special press now this increased
the durability of the card and also
accelerated its processing at the
checkout let me see why the information
of the charger plate didn't need to be
rewritten in this way a piece of copy
paper was actually placed on top of the
card and pressed down from above now an
exact copy instantly appeared on the
form with all of the necessary
information printed out the main means
of protection against fraudsters was the
complexity of making such a card it was
much more difficult to forge a steel
plate than a simple paper card now you
need to understand here special tools
and also the skills of working in a
locksmith's workshop were needed here in
addition the font was developed by the
company specifically for these tokens
very difficult to forge and by the way
doesn't this font remind you something
well it should do it's still used by
many payment systems today
take out your visa or mastercard the
number in your name are printed in the
same farringdon 7b font of course such
complexities did not frighten away the
scammers they stole real tokens then
cast lead mattresses on them and stamped
dozens of identical cards
then they drove all over america and
collected goods on credit as you can
imagine
and by the way there wasn't a single
processing endeavor either so you know
the companies had to calculate losses in
annual reports and this was the case
until banks became interested in a new
means of payment now this charge it card
is the world's first bank credit card
and appeared in 1946 in brooklyn john
biggs also used a steal token only
squeezed out on it not the name of the
owner but the bank account number two
now this system worked extremely simply
the only used the card to pay for
purchases the seller made an impression
of the card filled out the receipt and
then handed over to the bank to get the
money and after that the bank debited
the money spent from the cardholders
account now at first the system worked
only in brooklyn and was intended
exclusively for local operations the
issue of forgery or theft was not really
given much attention either such cards
were paid
day after day in some places now in
extreme cases the owner of the store
could actually call the bank and use the
account number to clarify the name of
the card holder isn't that a bit like
modern two-factor authentication well
probably yeah now it's pretty clear that
in a large supermarket the cashier
wouldn't call the bank about every
unfamiliar customer and therefore bank
cards weren't an everyday payment method
[Applause]
now ibm engineers made a real
breakthrough here from the mid-40s
onwards they're looking for cheap and
capacious data storage methods that were
supposed to replace punch cards
large amounts of data were stored on
huge reels of magnetic tape but the
company was looking for a way to quickly
transmit short messages now in 1960
forrest perry combined old and new
technology he pasted a piece of magnetic
tape onto the back of a punch card and
manually dragged it through the reader
now the prototype survived only a couple
of read write cycles the tape came off
the card and also broke but the idea
confirmed its right to live it's linked
to the central computer by the existing
telephone network
computer online
the shop is identified by pressing a
button please insert your card
the customer's magnetically coded card
links his bank account with that of the
shop now the technology was improved by
perry's wife she actually suggested
melting magnetic strips into the plastic
itself for prototypes this was done with
home irons now it took two years to
bring this idea into commercial use but
even with mass production such cards
remain too expensive each of them came
with a cost of around two dollars in
terms of today's prices that would be
more around 20. and imagine 20 for
issuing a card
why are you still complaining about your
bank's rates today however by the early
70s the cost of card production was
reduced to 5 cents in addition around
this time the company actually launched
equipment that was able to work with
cards i'm talking cash registers
scanners and terminals advertising
booklets promised fast and secure
payments too
pin the personal identification number
quickly became a key element of security
here
[Music]
[Applause]
admit it you probably remember opening
your very first pin envelope right in
fact before you this code really wasn't
seen by anyone at all in the entire
world envelopes actually arrive at the
bank sealed
inside the envelope there's a special
printing layer as on copy paper a
special printer shoots needles on the
envelope from the outside so the pin can
actually be printed on the inside but
why is this process so complex why does
it need to be also the bank can claim
that only you know the pin
and this clearly confirms your identity
the system quickly attracted the
attention of banks and of course
criminals and a lot of surprises waiting
for them to look i'm going to show you
something
this is a modern card and it comes with
its own magnetic stripe in fact some
cards don't even have these usable
magnetic stripes anymore it's just a
decorative element
the use of the system has long been
recognized as well too unsafe only a few
banks actually choose to leave it in for
compatibility purposes with outdated
equipment but what's wrong with the tape
well the fact is
the data is really too easy to copy what
you see here is a visualization of data
on the magnetic stripe of bank card
dashes are zeros and ones just like in a
barcode and in this picture they are
visible due to small magnetic particles
now in these two tracks you'll find all
of the card's data its number its
expiration date the owner's name even
several service codes in fact there's
actually enough space for one more track
and it was indeed provided for only now
it's rarely used and nobody really wants
to remember it at all it's often said
that it was made to store additional
information from specific companies i'm
talking about bonus miles loyalty points
etc but in fact pin was stored on first
cards so if the terminal didn't have
access to the network it was assumed
that this code would be used to confirm
the identity of the owner remember what
i told you about pin envelopes was it
even worth bothering with the system if
the code could be obtained from the card
itself
[Music]
social security was obviously abandoned
in the very first years the car's usage
as you can imagine and since then a
fundamentally different approach has
been used your pin is stored only in
your head please be so kind as to enter
a password of your choice shouldn't be
in any computer system either when you
enter a pin on the atm keyboard it's not
transmitted anywhere in the open such a
keyboard is actually a small crypto
computer it encrypts the pin and
transmits the results to the relevant
bank and the question is probably
playing around in your mind if the pin
is so securely encrypted and is not
stored anywhere why are there so many
leaks where pins of real cards appear on
the network do hackers just go through
millions of variants and match them up
no of course not they lure and steal
using social engineering luring
effectively means that the victim
themselves transmits to the attacker all
of the necessary information for payment
a whole arsenal of social engineering
methods is used here from fake websites
to fake friends and i've already told
you about this in a plethora of our old
videos now i'm interested in stealing
for the first time ever cbs journalists
drew attention to the massive theft of
credit cards in december 2002 they
discovered a new type of hacker device
that could record the names account
numbers and other identifying
information from the magnetic stripes
that could be downloaded onto a personal
computer later and that is how the
townsfolk learnt about skimmers these
are effectively devices that criminals
attach to the card readers of ordinary
atms and you've probably heard about
these
but contrary to popular beef skimmers
don't actually have to be small for
example these guys in brazil weren't too
lazy to actually make a whole fake panel
for an atmosphere
now while you insert the card into the
atm the skimmer reads the data from the
magnetic stripe and depending on the
design skimmers either save the data or
immediately sell it to a hacker over the
network
but this is only half of the battle it's
important for a hacker to steal your pin
too and without it a copy of a credit
card can well cost a couple of dollars
on the black market at most and it's not
so difficult to steal a pin either
firstly the pin can be stolen using a
miniature video camera this is actually
how most card thieves operated in the
early 2000s atms actually began to
protect themselves by equipping visors
around the code entry field you know
there's weird mirrors that you see when
you go to take money out of the atm well
the second approach is keyboard overlays
you enter the pin without noticing
anything and the thin lining remembers
which keys you pressed and then
everything was pretty simple blanks for
bank cards are openly sold for a couple
of cents a piece devices for recording
the information on the magnetic tapes
just cost a few hundred dollars
and in the end making clones of stolen
cards was easier than figuring out where
to spend the proceeds and i'm not
exaggerating her either in 2003
customers who used an atm to new york
delhi lost two hundred thousand dollars
in one day now on the other hand the
scale of skimming at the beginning of
the century is extremely difficult to
estimate authorities initially denied
everything just look at this guy from
bulgaria
[Music]
now this is constantine kavrakov in 2015
he was arrested for stealing hundreds of
other people's cards and among them a
clone of the microsoft founders card was
found in his wallet in addition to these
security problems cards with a magnetic
stripe had another problem they were
incredibly outdated if you work to
silicon valley in those years then your
contactless pass for the office or maybe
your garage keychain well they were more
crypto resistant and secure than your
credit card now payment systems decided
to take matters into their own hands
here and this is how the emv standard
appeared
[Music]
the name itself already has a lot here
and it was hard to imagine that sworn
competitors europa mastercard and visa
would actually unite to create a common
product but they did
this the brain of the new bank card was
this chip and it's very similar to the
phone's sim card and works pretty much
on the same principle when you insert a
card into an atm electricity is supplied
to the chip and it turns into a small
computer it solves the tasks of
encrypting traffic generating unique
keys and can even run small applications
for each operation here the chip creates
an individual confirmation code
therefore data intercepting during
payment becomes meaningless but most
importantly the chip cannot be copied it
has a closed memory area that cannot be
read and copied from the outside in
production unique data is recorded in
this area once and for all they're used
in cryptographic calculations and also
verification algorithms without copying
this area it won't be possible to make a
clone of the card the most vulnerable
link of this emv is the same magnetic
stripe it was inherited from the old
cards themselves
the european payment system mastercard
announced actually this summer that they
will abandon permanently magnetic strips
by 2023
so i think we can say philippa skimmers
into the history books of cyber
forensics
or can we well here's the thing the
potential threat lurks elsewhere in this
way we're going to talk about
contactless payment cards or rather the
people who use them
if you're watching my channel then i'm
sure that you already have a contactless
bank card but have you actually ever
wondered how it works well in fact just
like an emv it's just that the computer
processor has grown long antennas
look at this card
this specifically is the one that i used
to get into my building and when you
hold something like this up to a bright
light you might be able to see these
loops right and actually coils a very
thin wire and when they're in the
presence of a strong magnetic field a
current actually appears in them now it
all sounds quite scary but it works kind
of like wireless charging for your
smartphone the difference is that the
car doesn't have a battery in it so it
doesn't actually store any energy
without an external field the card's
dead can't be used but in the field of a
special nfc reader the card not only
receives energy but is also capable of
transmitting and also receiving
information the working distance is not
large ranging from a few millimeters to
seven or even ten centimeters and this
is done intentionally to complicate the
interception of information by an
attacker and of course to save energy
right
and this all together is called near
field communication nfc thanks to
journalists and skimmer hysteria we're
in constant fear that our precious
credit card may be cloned
i don't know about you but i'm still
reflexively trying to pick up the card
reader and keyboard when i actually see
unfamiliar atms what about you
well anyway skimmers can still be found
in places like latin america eastern
europe or even southeast asia and now
the imagination draws a picture of a
hacker approaching a contactless card
with a reader
scary
not at all because this really isn't
worth being afraid of
[Music]
anyway
let's get back to the question of the
reader's power let's say it won't work
to increase the capacity of a standard
banking device right you can assemble an
nfc reader with your own hands behold
it's my creation now in any good diy
electronic store you'll easily find half
a dozen different nfc modules right now
i took the first chip with a remote
antenna and i connected it to the good
old arduino uno here all you then need
to do is take a remote battery like this
one i've got from bosch and
plug it in
now you can see here on the screen
we've got an nfc scanner by samsung
now might be possible to read a card
with it but we'll have to check if i
stack three or four cards the reader
gives an error it can't correctly
process several incoming signals at the
same time if a thin piece of foil or
even several layers of clothing get
between the antenna and the card the
signal isn't able to pass so there's no
need to spend a heap of money on an
expensive wallet with nfc protection a
stack of old cards works no worse and
even in ideal conditions i can't read
meaningful information from a bank card
the information exchange protocols are
closed so i would have to spend many
years selecting the right commands and
obviously debugging the code in any case
it's impossible to get into the secured
part of the chip anyway
it turns out that nfc cards are secure
in the same way as regular chip cards
right right dude well
not really i recently learned about a
very beautiful method of intercepting
nfc card data
take a look at this footage
the hacker places a scanner antenna
between the payment terminal and the
phone with its help it records the
entire data exchange when making a
regular payment the scanner doesn't
interfere only eavesdrops on the
information so the payment goes through
without a hitch
only now the hacker has a dump in his
hands from which you can pull out the
full number and expiration date of the
assessment card now they can be used
under the cnp card not present
transaction payment scheme if you try to
intercept traffic from a real card then
theoretically you can determine its
number and then use it in a store that
doesn't use two-factor authentication
and then forgets to ask you for your cvc
right
the bad news is that there are almost no
such stores left
and why bother with an nfc scanner in
logs when an ordinary hidden camera
would be so much easier i mean really
it's quite easy to spy on numbers that
way
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
these words are actually from arthur c
clarke and they best describe the
attitude of people towards new things
ultimately we're afraid of things that
we don't understand
and therefore today in order to answer
the question of whether contactless
payments are really dangerous i actually
have to go back to the past i hope that
now you understand the differences
between the imaginary and the real
threats of nfc chips and don't shy away
from transport couriers with pos
terminals in their hands and certainly
don't add things made of aluminium foil
to your wardrobe
if you care about financial security
don't wait for mastercard to remove the
magnetic strips from your cards just
discard them in favor of more modern
ones well while travelling through the
curly whirly wonky wacky and wild
offline jungle it might be worth keeping
a small stack of bank notes at hand
they're immune from power outages don't
you know well my name is bradley peake
this is some sub and thanks for joining
us we'll see in the next video
[Music]
you